three two one
awesome I'm here I'm here oh just one
second let me catch my breath once upon
a time that roast us the most Magical
Kingdom founded by a king with the power
to grant wishes you are the handsomest
most beloved King you're right I am a
handsome king
I'm so nervous I think I'm going to
explode my best friend the king's
Apprentice oh my mouth trooping I feel
like they're scooping
Asha come with me
of roses wow people give their wishes to
me and I read the wishes I am sure are
good for Roses some of these will never
be granted that's
um most they deserve more than I decide
what everyone deserves
[Music]
so I look up at the stars to guide me I
wish
into every warning sign
thank you oh you spoil us with your
magic I didn't do it what
last night I made a wish on a star
uh I'm a star answered
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low I believe I've
just been threatened who would dare
threaten you
I have no response to that
there is a traitor amongst us find us
it's a dead end with unsanded mahogany
oh
fine Valentino my butt found it
I started this I have to finish it
what are you hiding nothing
and nobody what is going on in there
okay ladies your wings can't fly but
your voices
oh